.
JOHN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JIM BITTERMAN FOR US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
REPORT.
APPRECIATE IT.
BRIANNA.
>>> SO UKRAINIAN COUNTERATTACK
NORTH AND WEST OF KYIV APPEARS
TO HAVE MADE SOME HEADWAY.
THIS IS VIDEO THAT WAS REDUCED
AND POSTED BY THE REGIONAL
POLICE IN KYIV WHO TOURED THE
CITY OF MOCKRRIV.
UKRAINIAN FORCES SAY IT IS STILL
BEING HIT BY RUSSIAN ARTILLERY.
IF THEY ARE ABLE TO CONSOLIDATE
CONTROL IN THIS AREA, IT WOULD
LIMIT THE ABILITY TO ATTACK
KYIV.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS WITH
CONTRIBUTOR TO "TIME" MAGAZINE,
KIMBERLY DOZIER.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT REALLY
STANDS OUT AS A WUBG TA
UKRAINIANS PUSHING BACK,
BRINGING THE FIGHT TO RUSSIANS.
>> WELL, YOU CAN SEE IT IS IN
CONTESTED AREAS INSIDE THE AREAS
THAT RUSSIA HAS BEEN TELLING.
THEY HAVE TAKING BACK KEY
STRATEGIC I AREAS.
THIS WASN'T SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
THEY WERE TRYING TO ENCIRCLE
KYIV.
SOMETHING THEY THOUGHT WOULD
HALF HAPPEN IN 24 TO 48 HOURS.
EVEN AREAS LIKE IRPIN ARE
CONTESTED AS THE FORCES PUSH
BACK.
EVEN THE RIVER IS FLOODED, WHICH
IS BLOCKING RUSSIAN TROOP
PROGRESS.
SO IT'S LIKE EVEN NATURE IS
FIGHTING AGAINST THEM.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
I WAS WONDERING WHY IT WAS
FLOODED.
THERE WERE SOME QUESTIONS OUT
THERE.
IT REALLY IS JUST THIS CHANGE.
>> YEAH.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE CHANGE IN
THE WEATHER.
SO YOU HAVE THIS INCREASING
FLOW.
CAN WE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
RUSSIAN FORCES.
JIM TOUCHED ON THIS A BIT.
THEY HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCING A
LOT OF HEAD WINDS, AND WE KNEW
THAT.
NOW THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
FROSTBITE.
>> YES.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS THAT THEY
ARE INTERCEPTING COMMUNICATIONS
WHERE THE RUSSIAN TROOPS SAY
THEY ARE DEMORALIZED.
THEY CAN'T ALWAYS PICK UP THEIR
DEAD AND WOUNDED.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE SOME OF THE
BASIC SUPPLIES THAT U.S. TROOPS
ARE USED TO TRAVELING WITH.
AND THEIR LOGISTICS LINES ARE
STILL PRETTY VERBAL.
THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF FOOD.
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE
LOCATED ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THIS IS THE KIND OF THING THAT
NATO WORKED WITH THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY TO FIX.
>> IS THIS WHAT WE SEE AS
BELARUS GETS INTO THE FIGHT?
.
>> YES.
RUSSIA DEPLOYED ABOUT 75% OF ITS
TACTICAL BATTALIONS, THE COMBAT
FORCES IT USES TO PROSECUTE THIS
TYPE OF INVASION.
THAT MEANS IF THE BATTLE LOSSES
ARE AS REPORTED BETWEEN 7,000 TO
10,000 KILLED IN ACTION, WHEN
YOU ADD A RATIO OF THREE TO FOUR
WOUNDED, YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TROOPS OFF
THE BATTLEFIELD.
THEY NEED REINFORCEMENTS.
BELARUS SHARES A BORDER ARE
UKRAINE.
THEY KNOW HOW TO COMMUNICATE
WITH EACH OTHER.
AND HE OWES HIS PRESIDENCY TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BECAUSE WHEN HE WAS ELECTED IN A
CONTESTED ELECTION THAT THE U.S.
DIDN'T RECOGNIZE A COUPLE YEARS
BACK AND THERE WERE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF BELARUSIANS ON THE
STREETS PROTESTING AGAINST IT,
PUTIN SENT IN RUSSIAN TROOPS TO
REINFORCE HIS LEND KEEP HIM
IN POWER.
SO HE OWES HIS PRESIDENCY TO
MOSCOW.
.
>>ST I KNOW BERMAN HAS A
QUESTION TO YOU FROM LVIV.
>> YEAH, KIM.
I KNOW YOU FOLLOW THE DEFENSE
MINISTRY AND THE STATEMENTS THEY
MAKE.
THEY SUGGEST, YEAH HE YES, WHILE
THEY ARE MOUNTING EFFORTS
PARTICULARLY AROUND KYIV, THE
RUSSIANS MAY BE USING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO REGROUP SO
RELAUNCH EFFORTS SOON.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, IN THE
EASTERN PART THEY CONTINUE TO
TRY TO PERHAPS TRAP THE
UKRAINIANS IN THE FAR EAST IN AN
ENCIRCLING MANEUVER THERE.
>> THAT WOULD MEAN SOMEBODY ON
THE RUSSIAN BATTLEFIELD IS
STARTING TO USE PRETTY SMART
TACTICS.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF CONFUSION
AND NOT A LOT OF COORDINATION
AMONG THEIR TROOPS.
BRITISH INTELLIGENCE IS PUTTING
THIS OUT THERE SO UKRAINIANS GET
A HEADS-UP TO TRY TO COUNTER
THAT MANEUVER.
PART OF THE BACK AND FORTH THAT
YOU SEE ON THE BATTLEFIELD THAT
SHOWS YOU THIS IS